à
comme péter walton
bonjour à tous nous allons aujourd'hui
avant dé la partie italienne et plus
particulièrement fawcett au 4e ou donc
du point de vue des noirs après les
coûts de 4,5 avec les trois caves et les
c6 le ouf ou c4 est constitutif de la
partie italienne
les blancs sortent leur [ __ ] cases
blanches et souhaiterait ensuite
poursuivre par ces trois puits des
cadres concrètement après la réponse 4e
6 il faut bien protéger le point 4 ce
qui fait que le plan c'est 3 puis des
quatre doit être un peu revue les blancs
jouent le plus souvent d2 d3 à ce moment
mais le cook avait léger simple plus
agressive est possible aussi c'est
d'ailleurs une spécialité du grand
maître short et aussi de la période
romantique
après quatre des 3 nous arrivons dans le
vif du sujet avec poussettes les noirs
ont deux autres choix qu'ils sont fous
ces 5 et 6 qui empêche qu'avaient les g5
suivi deux des six g6 et fou g7
l'intervalle et de flou 7 par rapport
aux de l'autre et qui sera lente et
probablement moins compliqué pratiquer
du point de vue des noirs que font ces
cinq qui nécessite un plus grand travail
théorique fawcett est solide et après
des 6 et noir vont menacer cavalia 5
pour prendre la peur de fous ils vont
effectuer le petit rock et ensuite
choisir entre différents plans que nous
allons voir
après 5 petit rock petit rock les blancs
jouent traditionnellement six tours 1
dans l'idée d'empêcher le coup
libérateur d7 d5
en effet après à prendre les cinq
cavaliers prend des cinq le pion aux 5
serait envers les noirs sont donc plus
ou moins forcé de jouer 17 10 6
instaurant la menace cavaliers à 5 pour
aller prendre le pouls c4 ce qui motive
le coup suivant de blanc cette a4 qui
vise à prendre de l'espace sur la dame
les noirs ont ensuite plusieurs plans à
leur disposition le plus agressif est
temps sans doute
roy a ensuite suivi de cavaliers vide et
f7 f5 pour essayer d'attaquer sur
l'aileron
il ya deux autres façons de traiter
cette position le coup cavaliers à 5 et
ensuite sur le retrait ou à deux les
noirs jours et c'est cette c5 et les
positions ressemblerait à un hybride
espagnoles et italiennes
les noirs n'ont pas encore joué à six et
b5
mais cela viendra peut-être l'autre
façon serait de jouer 7 h 7 h 6 comme
dans ma partie contre série noire cela
que nous allons voir
et ensuite le plan le plus courant et
cavaliers h cette cave et léger simple
pour échanger ce cavalier contre le
cavaliere 3 l'échangé favorable noir
pour deux raisons le contrôle des blancs
du centre et notamment de la case des
quatre serait amoindrie et par ailleurs
et noir et n'y a au moins des espaces il
est respectable pour eux d'alléger leurs
positions en échange
des pièces donc revenons à 7 h 6 j'ai
joué à 4 à 5 à 7 à 6 et maintenant le
choix de blanc s'articule entre 9 c3
toujours pour occuper le centre avec des
trois des cadres ou cavaliers c3 afin
aimant ce nom d'années ont des 5 avec le
cavalier ou de jouer d3 d4 reprend des
quatre cavaliers prendre des quatre les
blancs un petit avantage
l'espace leur poussée 4 est un peu plus
fort que son homologue le full recettes
et donc les blancs ont des chances
raisonnables d'obtenir un petit
davantage d'ouverture après neuf
cabinets c3 cyril avait choisi faux et
six dans la partie qui nous avons posé
au lieu de câblage 7 puis kevin et g5
que j'ai mentionné avant j'avais conclu
cavaliers des 5
et là je pense que les blancs étaient
déjà un peu mieux puisque la réaction
fonds prend des 5e prend des cinq
cavaliers b4 n'étaient pas adéquates
pour les noirs à cause de 12 ces trois
cavaliers b prend des cinq dames b3
suivi de dames premier set et
l'échangent du plan des 5 contre le clan
des sept se révèle favorable blanc
puisque et maintenant le pion noir a6
est devenu une cible
après dix cavaliers des 5 séries a joué
le coup surprenant car lycées 6 des 8
afin de chasser le cavalier des cinq par
c7 c6 et de rebondir par cavalier 8 17
à ce moment j'ai décidé de jouer des
trois des caps pour essayer de profiter
de la vence de développement et surtout
du développement qualitativement
meilleure des blancs en ouvrant le
centre si elle a répondu fou g4 et
maintenant les blancs pouvaient déjà
prendre un avantage durable en
s'emparant de la paire de fou soit par
cavalier point 7.7 précédé ou pas de
l'échangé des points 5 soit par des
points 5 des provinces 5 h 3 pour
prendre le pouls de cases blanches
j'ai préféré jouer douze cavaliers 23
avec l'idée de replacer ce cavalier f5
où il sera dans la partie agressivement
poster pour agacer le roi noir
après douze cavaliers trois faux
problème 3 1 3 3 les noirs sont revenus
par cavalier c6 exerçant une pression
sur le chef des quatre sur quoi j'ai
répondu des quatre des cinq cas validé
quatre mdm et maintenant après qu'avait
l'épreuve 1 4 ces trois cavaliers b5 et
blanc avaient un choix entre récupérer
leurs pions immédiatement par fou prend
b5 apprend d59 détroit où le peu de la
partie 17 cavaliers f5 qui me plus
séduit puisque les blancs ont de très
bonnes chances d'attac à base de damas
trois fonds prend 1,6 ou parfois câble
et 3 6 échecs
la partie va se terminer brillamment par
17 cavaliers m6 dame f3 pardon dam des
trois attaquants le cavalier b5 et
menaçant surtout fo prend 1,6 g prend h6
d'objets trois échecs subis limmat
cyril a répondu dame 17 qui est une
grosse faute
et après fou prend 1,6 l'avantagent
blanc qui est déjà quasiment décisif la
suite de la partie et cavalières 8 d'un
match 3 le fourrage 6 est toujours
imprenable à cause de câbles hypron à 6
échecs suivi de dame prend dame ton des
huit protège la dame 17 food étroits
avec des idées de la th 7 et après fo et
6 supra g7 et noir ont abandonné à cause
de la menace cavaliers cet échec celui
de damages sept matches revenons
quelques coups avant avec le 7e coup des
noirs ici nous avons vu le coût h 7 h 6
comme je les mentionnaient dans un tweet
est une option intéressante aussi avec
l'idée qu'un léger vite puis f 7 5
c'est comme ça que la partie entre matt
hill congiu et laurie delorme du top 16
de cette année s'est poursuivie après
7,3 à 8 8 à 5 à 6 les blancs jouer
qu'avec les c3 un coût qui me semble
simple et suffisamment prometteur pour
les blancs et après cavaliers g8 d3 d4
10 coup j'ai 4.5 et noir ont répondu dès
prendre 5 qui les a conduits à défendre
une finale difficile
en effet après 12 d'emprunt des huit
tours apprend des huit food et 5 fu
preuve 3g prend 1,3 pardon faut prendre
trois fous processus d'abord 14 les
procès 6g premier 3 les deux camps ont
dépuis en doublettes mêlées pions f des
blancs peuvent facilement se dédoubler
par f3 f4 tandis que les pions c'est
noir
on restait faible un long moment 15
poule b 4 16 f 4 maintenant les noirs
auraient pu infliger aussi des pions
c'est leur adversaire par fou prend 6 3
les princes et rois mais cela n'aurait
pas suffi à résoudre leurs problèmes
puisque les blancs avaient ensuite
disposer de la manoeuvre tour à quatre
c4 pour viser les pions c'est inverse
après seize f4e prend 1,24 faut prendre
quatre matile conjugaux a obtenu un bon
avantage dans la finale qui n'a pas
réussi à concrétiser mais n'était pas
loin pour conclure je dirais que ce
système est relativement facile à
apprendre du côté des noirs mais il a
quand même beaucoup de nuances à
maîtriser pour pouvoir réaliser le plan
des blancs la plus prometteuse est sans
doute joué avec taurin pour empêcher d7
d5 puis à 4 à 5 pour prendre de l'espace
sur la dame ensuite choisir entre eurois
ensuite cliquer d'éligibilité de 5
ou bien h six cavaliers h7